yeah we're back spent a good day so far
UFOs are back in the news
did you hear about that no I've been
working on my book I've ever read I've
been reading about murders all day it's
not really back in the news it's just
that everybody is now it seems like
everybody on my [ __ ] feed including I
think maybe some must have been
mentioned in the news they're talking
about how the the air for the Air Force
and the Navy the Pentagon that is that
the Pentagon is is verifying all them
damn UFO videos that the Navy took yeah
this goes back to 2015 yeah I was gonna
say yeah but it's just like yeah that's
real you know we don't know what that is
is he it's a UAV or you AF are you ap
it's what they call it right
unidentified aerial aerial phenomena
okey
yeah but showing yeah yeah yeah I don't
know man that's just some weird stuff
that little dot going across the top of
the ocean then locking onto it and all
the pilots go whoa whoa what is that
there's no [ __ ] heat signature of any
kind of heat coming off of it you know
cuz I know you know I had a jet rocket
right or a rocket jet ramjet when I was
a kid yeah you know remember I told that
story actually my dad bought it he made
the excuse me the excuses for me but
says so he could buy it well yeah that's
how dad's all over the world and I say
back in the 70s it was seasoned aluminum
I guess they were aluminum metal look
like a damn ramjet with a single wing on
it from way I remember it you put
alcohol in it it was on the end of a
string and you soon it would ignite
itself and start screaming that succored
scream around you'd have it on a wire
must be about a hundred hundred foot of
wire you can add more wire if you want
it to you know there's no this before
radio control well they had radio
control just too expensive
yeah just selling wire controlled you
know you could get
to go up and down that was it and you
just sling it around a sucker my
speckling about 300 miles an hour I mean
screaming you know then when it would
run out of fuel it hit the ground bounce
you know it was metal and I'd run up to
it don't touch it don't touch it and
that sucker be sitting there just
smoking yeah
redhot back when we had dangerous toys
where you could put your eye out like
never more squishy that's like a monkey
waves coming off that thing I think must
have been a [ __ ] thousand degrees man
it's like look it's getting rid of melt
no spec needs to sell a [ __ ] like that
cuz I remember one of my favorite toys
me and my brother had when we were
growing up was this [ __ ] they would
sell you that [ __ ] where you could make
urine like they had the thing maker and
then they had that one thing that would
looked like a little foundry and you
could like melt wax disks or your
crayons if you were into that and you
could make little like match box type
cars out of wax you know what I mean
like you could put like the little axles
in the wheels in there and then melt wax
a room and like make and also they
double those crayons yeah and it was
super super hot I also had the Holly
Hobbie Easy Bake Oven used to make
little tiny pies in there and [ __ ] like
that but you know I'm just looking at
these ten looking at these damn can't a
gun camera footage in the sensors and
you would think something small like
that just going as fast as it would
would just be you know burning red hot
if you given a huge heat signature huge
plume out the back of it and nothing
just a dot you know said dot from da
alien yeah and the plane saw it you know
they've got all the sensors it was there
everybody else and airplanes can see it
then another one where they were behind
it and it just they're tracking and good
thing they just went it just took off
let me just vanish and they were going
you know hundreds of miles an hour when
they were looking at it and no no plume
or anything just unidentified aerial
phenomena yeah I don't think I don't
think I don't think we have any kind of
propulsion system it doesn't that can go
that fast it doesn't put out any heat
not that we know of it no but we got to
give a shout out on a movie sit okay we
got a
we got two packages two little packages
someone named Joseph who had been
talking to me on Facebook and said that
he was sending us some stuff like a care
package yeah you got it yesterday late
yesterday afternoon yeah he gave me a
badass patch a black patch for the
[ __ ] from Joy Division with little
[ __ ] I don't know the reich's boom to
[ __ ] beat the drum little kid you
know yeah like that very old like Joy
Division division logo yes yes when they
had become well they were worse on then
they became Joy Division yeah and this
all Germanic it should look pretty cool
I got that so put that on your
motorcycle jacket yeah I was checking
but it I don't really have a place for
it on there it's gonna be too big oh
I'll figure out something to do with it
yeah maybe put it on a pair of pants we
got a Depeche Mode one-tail yeah yeah
that would be cool actually put it on
pair of like black pants somewhere cuz I
got some ones pretty cool pants yeah and
then I got some movies yeah got
Winchester yeah I gotta watch that one I
wanted to see that we did a show about
the Winchester Mystery House yeah
Beetlejuice we watched that one last
night yeah yeah watch that let's say I
love that Jenny wanted to get back into
that I thought - this is the one I'm
waiting on my Rudy ray Moore dolomite I
says right here man is this this is the
[ __ ] greatest [ __ ] review of all
times the title for review it says the
Citizen Kane of kung fu pimpin movies
see it's like that the New York Times I
mean you have to watch it with the
tagline this Citizen Kane of Kung Fu
Panda movies man you got [ __ ] Rudy
Ray's [ __ ] of a face right there what's
a looks like yeah looks like after Eddie
Murphy's movie came out as mine I guess
I guess after that movie came out
decided to re-release the don't really
raise movies I noticed that on I think
it was on to be when I was like looking
through the [ __ ] they had the other day
they have a reading reimu v that you can
watch for free I believe it's called PT
wheat straw in the devil's son-in-law
okay time to watch it yet but I'm like
well I gotta [ __ ] watch that I saw a
tea
Murphy's movie if you guys haven't seen
it it's on Netflix it's probably still
on Netflix I would think I think it is
yeah it's called dolomite is my name and
it's probably one of the best movies of
that year I really enjoyed that I did
too I like that I could not believe that
Eddie Murphy was back and he was back
[ __ ] strong yeah it was like the
Eddie Murphy that I grew up with like
high quality Eddie Murphy and he plays
he plays Rudy Rae yeah and it's like a
duck it's like a comedy docudrama it's
like a real-life story about this guy
all right if you guys haven't seen it go
[ __ ] see that flick it is hilarious
it's hilarious and it made me want to
see these movies I hadn't seen him yeah
but I only saw Dolomites it was a long
time ago and Rudy Rae is making these
movies yeah that's what the movie it's
about his like the start of history our
bodies rancid making wrong it's a real
feel-good movie and it's uh it's just
hilarious you know it is so now I have a
chance to see a high quality Rudy ray
movie really read more movie effect if
it's good I'll get more of them I've
heard they're amusing but the quality is
spotty it is some of them are better
than others but it's just like Ed Wood
just I can't boo it you know it's like
some of them are more fun than others
yeah um some other things that were in
this like look at all the stuff that he
sent you guys so you got I got the CD
this is a baby cold I don't know if you
can see that since white but it's
they're called waste there like a room
ik nose man like an industrial man and
I'm very excited about this and I'm
gonna make Tom play with me yeah is this
really cool Edward Gorey ask card game
called gloom yeah cool this looks
kick-ass we're gonna have to play it on
the show that would be really awesome
actually we take up the whole show you
can be like there's the Depeche Mode
patch I got the other patch then it's in
my closet yes so thank you very much
Joseph we were so so excited was I was
like oh boy it's like Christmas like
every day around here so uh oh the other
thing we wanted to talk about was on
shudder last night if you're on Tom
shitty movies and stuff I think that you
started this conversation here because
we had reviewed VFW which was directed
by Joe Vegas of course or
yeah that got a good response when I
posted that people people launched Tom
Shaye's liked a couple guys made a
comments about him and we had seen his
other movie bliss which came out in 2019
and we reviewed it and you didn't like
that um I liked it I you know I didn't
love it but I like to be have to be much
better but then somebody said oh yeah
he's good and he had another movie that
came out of 2015 called the mind's eye
which i think was actually his second
movie I'm not sure what the first one
was made for like 50 grand or something
yeah he told me to watch II he says it's
basically scanners - it is like sounded
good watched it it's exam shutter had
that one as well
it had like it pretty much had like his
three main movies yeah and it's it's um
it's got a kind of a junk it's got a
John Carpenter style scored it which I
liked it but it has a Cronenberg field
of the movie especially as it as it goes
on the longer the movies playing the
more Cronenberg it feels it's pretty
good it's kind of like Conan Bergen but
it does have a lot of carpenter s kana
yeah the crossover like a crossover it's
kind of like John Carpenter and and and
and Conan Berg making a movie together
that's kind of what's like yeah it
definitely did give me that land vibe
practical effects dudes getting their
hands split open yeah so many exploded
goth I so they got a security guy in
there that's [ __ ] you tell that okay
that snake blitz niklas a snake fish
yeah it's like a younger version of
Snake Plissken and he's a psychic - well
did he do some psychic [ __ ] he did very
any one thing yeah yeah cuz I guess he
about this dude who owns this so I can
Institute the study in psychokinesis
which is a pretty much the kind of the
same deal that you have out of scanners
yeah and and it's on of them was he's
got his own compound to private housing
a lot of the brood yeah okay
gave me a little bit of a dead zone vibe
yeah it's got a lot of dead zone cause
it's like wintry well there was another
one there that I was saying
it was there something has gone place
reminds me a lot of Christine or
something no what was it there's another
movie that I said that it reminded me of
a Cronenberg one or a director one I
think was a carpenter it doesn't matter
but it's a low-budget movie that's
punching way above its weight you could
tell that they really cared about the
movie when they made it real good shots
snow good scenery taking place in the
night in the early 90s yeah 1990s so you
have all the 80s kind of feel to it it's
good it's real good if you know if you
like the VFW go see this one I would say
VFW is better
yeah well VFW is a little more polish
yeah because this one you can I mean as
good as it is you can tell that it's
like had like a bit lower budget but the
practical effects are really really good
I mean we were just like we were sitting
around drinking watch it every time a
head exploited we were like yeah my only
gripe about it is that maybe like the
first the front half of that movie it
had a few scenes in it work was a little
too dialogue heavy for that genre
Cronenberg's is actually very stark it
is yeah and you know so was carpenter
carpenters dialogue was kind of you know
kind of kind of stark and slightly odd
too
you know like assault on precinct 13
doesn't really seem to have any natural
dialogue to it yeah dialogue sounds very
kind of witness tilted yeah a little bit
wrong but that's that's what made those
movies though there was something that
kind of gave a certain kind of vibe to
that movie that made it seem kana that's
a good word for it it elicits yeah or
something yeah yeah that's a weird thing
yeah well the front half of the movie
was a little too dialogue heavy in
certain areas explained too much don't
talk just show you know what I mean yeah
but the second half it really picked up
oh it definitely yeah it became the
movie I wanted it to be so overall I'd
still you know I'd give it an eight
10 for the type of movie that it is and
the guy playing the doctor was like
really he was great he was like [ __ ]
over the top and [ __ ] you reminded me
now you said it yeah it did remind me
another man from beyond yeah that's
right that oh yeah remember yeah the bad
guys it's kind of like the same bad guy
from from beyond yeah he crazy mad
scientist dick could do things doing the
impossible with like mental powers of
the pineal gland type [ __ ] it's like
that another another homage and I didn't
even think of this until later but the
the opening card of the movie that says
this movie should be played loud yeah
that was a reference to a driller killer
from Nike I think I came out in 1981
Abel Ferrara directed it he also did
miss 45 which I read a long time ago but
yeah so that's what uh that's what that
was an homage to you that was an homage
to driller killer yeah and the movie has
a great [ __ ] carpenter esque score ad
style score like a vapor were a new
retro wave type score touches a vapor
wave in it and so even if you're kind of
bored in the very beginning with done
the dialogue I was sitting there
drinking tequila I was jamming out to it
like he said and then at the end it
almost kind of goes it almost kind of
goes like like a phantasm movie yeah
like three or four one of the more
polished phantasm movies you know with
[ __ ] weird unexplained kind of
psychic phenomenon people's heads blown
up and violence I mean they didn't have
you know of course like
extra-dimensional little little midgets
you know kind of it kind of looked and
felt a little bit kind of like one of
the better
phantasm movies towards at the end yeah
I can see where you're saying although
I'd say that those practical effects
probably little bit better yeah I mean
that guy's head got split in half yeah
they're doing some really really good
like and then to say trauma in this
movie yeah the bad guys got like one of
his henchmen says like maybe I could
throw your old kind of Snake Plissken
type dudes
similar hair it kind of that same kind
of look that crustle has and he's got
the eyepatch but he's in a black suit
but he could kind of imagine that that
might be something snake would have done
for a little while or something after he
got out but the thing is I think he gets
killed in that movie
or did he get cured he no he ran off you
never saw him again did you remember
that well the whole time I was like
watching the movie because I I know I
just saw that actor at another movie
recently and it was driving me crazy
though I don't think that character got
killed never had they had that big fight
in that hallway and his partner remember
that he saw his head and you play picked
up the gun and then he [ __ ] just left
yeah and and I don't think he ever
showed back up again she mentioned this
he was kind of like [ __ ] you know maybe
I supposed to be snake he went off to do
like he had to go on to do escape from
me in 2008 or whenever that we have
never that was supposed to be clear that
was supposed to be ya know that was 1997
1997 that's right so that would R it
would work out yeah he's been about the
right age to rest that might have been
snake but if I think but I don't think
he died yeah now that you mentioned it I
don't think he did either because I
thought everyone got killed but then I
was kind of like oh thanks oh man I
gotta go back and see it again I think
he said [ __ ] it and left yeah I mean he
got badly hurt on a couple times yeah
during that you know me but he's just he
was like I have [ __ ] this and he left
now I'm never remembers yeah because I
don't think he had any like loyalty
doctor anything he was just like some
mercenary dude they still got into like
find the other psychic dude yeah I think
so and I think that was supposed to be
snake well who else would the duty loves
carpenter movies put a guy who looks
like that right yeah it's like that
seems like of course you would of course
you would or she would do that yeah he
did have lighter hair than Kurt Russell
though he had lived he was kind of
blonde a little bit but you could dye
your hair down yeah and it wasn't quite
as that long but it was that same hair
style it was and that was about that
same build in that same look
I think that was supposed I'm just gonna
well we're just gonna go with that we're
just gonna say thatthat see that
character til you guys who have seen it
the scene in which he died I don't think
he actually died yeah he might not have
now that yeah Casey might have taken off
before like the big main come from yeah
at the end not to see it again but yeah
so [ __ ] knock these things off yeah
she's like it's right there [ __ ]
look at me
she likes to push things off the table I
guess all cats like to do that but yeah
so that's probably all we got to talk
about right now it's like I said I just
been working on the book today and I was
actually writing about this one case
this is [ __ ] weird this happen in
2000 and it's like evidently there was
this guy in Pakistan and he was trying
to sell a mummy like on the black market
and he was gonna get in trouble for that
because apparently you're not allowed to
like sell cookies moving the camera
because you're not allowed to sell like
you know antiquities that were found in
Pakistan like outside of Pakistan you
know I mean that's the antiquities Act
so he was gonna get in trouble for that
and then so they seized the mummy and
they were everyone was excited about it
because it was like supposedly a Persian
princess it was kind of wrapped in an
Egyptian style but it was supposed to be
like the daughter of Xerxes or something
like that so everyone was like flipping
out like wow this is like a big like
deal but then when they started
examining it not only did they find out
that that it was a forgery because a lot
of the like keenya form and stuff was
not correct and like some of the like
the box that it was in was only like 250
years old but they found out that the
woman that had been wrapped as mummy had
been killed in 1996 oh so she was it
might have been a murder victim dance oh
yeah yeah so that's what I'm holding is
fake so that's what I've been raised I
don't know like if the people that
mummified her like for [ __ ] like killed
her or if they just had some connection
they have found a body or they just like
found it because because they thought
that like whoever this woman was that
she must have been mummified like within
24 hours of her dying which would
suggest that they either had a
connection that was like hey we got a
good body you can use like at the morgue
or what
or that they killed her themselves so
because still don't know who she was
some kind of organized crime thing you
know like that's kind of what I'm
thinking please to hide the body
would've been in the complaint site you
know yeah well sell to a rich person
although it would have been like if I
guess they were trying to get like a
[ __ ] ton of money by saying it's a
Persian mummy even though they didn't
make mummies in Persia but which drew
more attention to and obviously I mean
they were trying to get 11 million
dollars for the [ __ ] they even tried to
sell it to the met in New York but the
guy that looked at it was like yeah
that's a fake right not he didn't even
see the body he just saw pictures and he
could just tell from the inscriptions
he's like yeah that's not very very good
forgery but yeah it was like a
fascinating case and it's like you don't
really hate I had never heard of it
before and I just kind of found it while
I was looking for unsolved deaths in
2000 and I was like holy crap ins I
don't know if it's ever gonna be
resolved but most of the cases that I
write about are yeah something I read or
somebody out about me yeah maybe
this might figure out they don't even
know who the woman is or anything like
that but yeah so that'll probably do it
for today's show I think hope you guys
are enjoying the one that we put up
earlier about old Alfred Packer the
cannibal and also about the Donner Party
that was the why I had a good time doing
that show as you can tell it's that it
being all this four hours long we just
looked at you like you said something
wrong she's gonna be like that she was
looking at me all cockeyed like what she
doesn't [ __ ] off him yeah she has like
she had out the relations like what she
has really distinct facial ear she does
not like it when you yawn yeah that
really freaks her out you yawn right in
front of you yeah it was I guess she
doesn't know what it looks like from
someone else's perspective but like if I
yawn she looks at me like I'm a crazy
person
yeah stop it leave yeah
maybe she thinks somebody eat her head
or something like that I would never do
such a thing but yeah she's uh she's
sitting right there being crazy alright
it down so we're gonna wrap this up stay
safe and healthy out there you guys
we'll talk to you again tomorrow